good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at 4 o'clock i'm kirsten
joyce
and i'm christian goss that as well it's
the big topic today should clark county
pay you 100 dollars
to get vaccinated today commissioners
weighed that
option the i-team's david charns force
told us about the proposal
here last week and he joins us live here
in studio david did they make a decision
well quick answer is no they didn't they
put this on hold
and other topics to talk to groups like
the state and city about
how they would do this to pay people to
get vaccinated
now we told you last week commissioner
tick sega bloom proposed paying people
100 bucks to get the vaccine
a lot of people mostly against the
vaccine and masks
took to the public comment today with
the state mask
mandate in place right now commissioners
have no power over masks
the majority of speakers who came to the
meeting say the county should spend this
money elsewhere
why don't we spend that 10 million
dollars trying to figure out where all
these missing children go
how about that's more important than
covid which had kids have a 99.995
surviving if you believe in god
perhaps this is the thing that's meant
to bring us together it's not supposed
to be political it's not supposed to
break us apart
this thing is killing human beings
period now the commission again took no
action on this incentive
several commissioners voicing concern
about spending the proposed
10 million dollars that would cover 100
000 people to get that 100 several of
the panel members say they were open to
other incentives and they're going to
talk about this
in a couple weeks now remember this is
in addition to the state's program
already underway that's nevada days